I'm at the food nutrition conference and
Expo this year it's held in Philadelphia
I'm an the Expo and I don't know where
to start
these are like really good and it's
really good good off and we're gonna
super rushed we gotta get home either
kiddo get changed get back in a cab and
then we're going to the Taste Canada
cookbook Awards tonight
[Music]
okay so it looks like there's like a
disco happening in the lobby here but
I'm going to go to the gym at the hotel
here I mean beautiful Philadelphia which
is a city that I totally love I'm
heading to the food nutrition conference
in Expo today so I'm really excited
about that but of course I did not sleep
super well I never sleep well I'm just a
bad sleeper in general you know
you still feel like I really want to
remove my body a little bit so it so I'm
usually the only person in the gym at a
hotel and that is the case today - and
that's surprising cuz usually a
dietitian conferences they're often like
tons of women in the gym early in the
morning so I have this whole place but
let's have a quick workout and I'll meet
you on the flipside okay so remember how
I said that it was like super quiet in
the gym and I had all to myself about
five minutes later an entire like pack
of women descended upon the weight rack
and like this tiny little gym I
basically had like 3x3 square footage to
workout in and so it wasn't my most
intense workout of life but I got I got
it done so I'm gonna go have a quick
shower I stole an apple from the gym so
this is gonna be a quick little quick
snack and and then we're gonna get ready
to go to the conference all right that
looks a little bit better I've got my
badge I'm ready to go to the conference
first we're gonna get a quick little
coffee and honestly I'm not even that
hungry other than I just had that Apple
but I'm still not really hungry for
breakfast which is unusual for me but we
got home really late didn't sleep well
and I ate like a really big deal which
is amazing so that pretty much explains
it so I'm just gonna eat when my body
tells me it's ready also this is
admittedly going to be a really random
eating day because I'm going to the
conference and I basically am going to
eat like so many samples usually I'm so
full from all the samples that I don't
really feel like having a full meal so
it's gonna be an interesting one so that
was the lineup for Starbucks apparently
people have already been waiting for
or I guess I'm not gonna get copy this
morning so I'm just gonna have to wait
it out and we go to open it so I don't
even know if I explained what I'm doing
here but basically I'm at the food
nutrition conference and Expo this year
it's held in Philadelphia
every year it's somewhere different and
basically I bring my husband
I didn't bring my baby this year so he
stayed home with Grandma and Grandpa but
we kind of make a little trip out of it
every single year and I go to a few
media events I go to the expo and
ultimately I want to kind of find all
the best new innovative food products
there are out there on the market so
that's what I'm going to be doing this
morning and of course I'm going to be
tasting them all so that's kind of gonna
be what a in this day even that's me
like a really random day and I'm really
excited because I get to see all my
dietician friends people who follow me
and and watch the videos a lot of them
are dieticians or kind of rd2 bees or
nutrition students so it's really fun to
kind of get to meet all the people that
support me so I'm really looking forward
to okay so the Expo is not even open yet
but I just want to know something in my
stomach to take
vitamins with so I got these little
under calorie packs they were giving the
mouth these are jalapeno cashews sounds
pretty good so yeah that's gonna be my
free breakfast snack I don't even know
what this meal is gonna be because it's
gonna be such a hodgepodge of little
nibbles and fights so bear with me okay
so I normally take my supplements at
that time but I'm on an antibiotic right
now so I need to kind of space them out
so I've bought my Omega threes my
prenatals my vitamin D and a probiotic
so I'm gonna get those in right now
before I totally forgot about that I'm
definitely starting to get hungry so I'm
excited for samples but I had such an
amazing dinner last night that
definitely was more food than I normally
would eat probably so I kind of held me
a little bit later into the morning you
guys know I'm a breakfast person I
normally even like three meals right now
just kidding
but at least like one or two so it's not
surprising that I'm starting to kind of
feel like I'm ready for a meal and I'm
ticked off and I didn't get my coffee
but you know we're gonna make it through
we're gonna push through all right here
I am I'm in the expo so let's do this
they're gluten free soy free oily grain
free
these are like really good firm and soft
I'm really really good okay so I just
ate like an entire bag of these adorable
little chickpea puffs they have four
grams of plant-based protein are super
delicious and they taste kind of like
like a cheesy so good
oh my gosh guys this granola
game-changer game-changer and it's
really good runoff it's like an ancient
grain Corolla
it's made with amaranth and millets with
dark chocolate it is so so good off this
on yogurt killer guys this is so good it
tastes like banana bread with peanut
butter standard on top
[Applause]
[Music]
so yummy
[Music]
give us away all right this is the only
time where I start to look like a pack
from live like so many bags on me and
anyways I've got this awesome little
dairy-free probiotic drink for my vegan
friends out there who want to get their
probiotics in this was like really
delicious and I love the quick little
movie size you can just take it wherever
you're going
[Music]
all right so my first little cute little
Jack through taco how sweet is that
[Applause]
it's really though if you guys are my
plant-based followers you're gonna want
to find that that product aid shot
[Music]
little peanut frozen that energy ball
[Applause]
is what
[Applause]
and so the perfect breakfast okay so I
feel like any little break from like all
the protein bars and protein shakes and
things like that but this is the non
smooth to good yogurt it's got 2 grams
of sugar it looks really yummy and I'm
definitely gonna have a little sample
[Applause]
[Music]
with the eggs
Derek okay so I just tried a watermelon
seed butter but which kind of tastes
like tahini and
so delicious and
rich and protein and all the good things
yum yum
I'm gonna make the best hummus with this
[Music]
just a quick little nosh
[Music]
all right so we are at the Quaker Oats
and they have little breakfast O'Neil
bar and I've got some sweets and some
savory Oh so
which is gonna win I don't know
that's good
my favorite let me know in the comment
when you are more inclined to go with
because this is gonna be a heated debate
sweet or savory okay so these are a
cauliflower coated chicken nuggets I'm
gonna see how they taste because if
they're really yummy I'm definitely
gonna buy them for maybe a page
I got the spicy ones and they're not too
spicy but they've got a nice little kick
[Music]
all right little ice-cream interlude
and sober
I love this stuff
honey ice cream is a friend of mine
I just sampled like every flavor of the
ice creams that enlightening so
they might need to restock right it is
breakfast time little pancake
that was so good okay folks so I think
I'm a little old sampled out I'm gonna
go pack my bag get myself ready to go
home on the flight I feel like I need a
walk after all those samples especially
because I feel like a lot of them have
like protein powder and also like
non-nutritive sweeteners in them which
tend to make me feel a little bit
bloated so I think I need to kind of
walk that off maybe get a coffee at some
point and get on my plane so let's do it
okay so it is raining outside and while
I have a little bit of time to kill
before I have to head out to the airport
I thought I would go through my little
goodie bag my little trick-or-treat bag
of some samples that I grabbed and share
with you some of my favorites but I
think you guys are gonna really like
we've got these no cheese cheesiness
snacks from lesser evil so these are
grain free they are vegan so for my
vegan friends who want that kind of
cheesy flavor but of course without the
cheese he's kind of taste like cheese
so really fun Vienna I'm a huge bianna
fan I love all their kind of crispy
chickpeas and I bought some of those
somewhere too but these are new these
are their chickpea puffs and I sampled
them they're delicious
I think my son would love them but
they've got 4 grams of protein in them
and they are really crispy and light and
just got a nice amount of cheesiness
without being a really salty and messy
so I love that these were amazing they
are these undercover quinoa snacks I got
the milk chocolate because I don't
really love dark chocolate I know
dietitian fail but it's just not for me
it's too bitter for me and so this milk
chocolate has crispy quinoa inside and
it tastes like a chocolate bar what does
that bar is a crunch bar that has the
like the little bits of crispy things
inside it is super super delish so I'm
really looking for
this one has currents in it and this is
just straight-up milk chocolate and
quinoa so a nice little nice little
treat for the the plane ride home I
think these are great if you haven't
tried 88 acres they've got a whole range
of different unique seed butters this is
the pumpkin seed and this is the
watermelon seed I was kind of eating out
the storm at the sample booth and I'm
really excited to put these in to good
use great for recipes look great for
recipes but also just for snacking these
are fun and they have Elmo on them so
I'm totally gonna bring these home for
baby II this is Earth's Best organic
throw peanut butter corn puffs so
actually this would make a really great
kind of wait to introduce peanut
products to babies assuming I don't know
how stretchy these are but they might be
a little bit too hard for for them but
for sure for tolerance and maintenance
when you've got a little bit of more of
a more experienced eater so these are
really really tasty and if you like
peanut butter and you like to snack on
crispy things I'm really excited baby
you know you're gonna have to share this
even with the Elmo he's gonna share with
Mama and then I've got some moon cheese
because I mean I guess it's all about
the crispy things this season this year
everyone loves a good crunch factor so
if you're craving some crunchy cheese
this is this is your jam and I tried
like a whole inch different flavors I
like the straight-up cheddar they have
Gouda they have like all sorts of
different combinations pepperjack they
think so yeah this is just cheese and
it's it's got proteins but 11 grams of
protein per pack so a great little snack
maybe we'll have this on the flight home
all right so I'm gonna catch up with my
husband I gotta figure out where he is
in the city
I got a final track him down without
getting caught in the rain
I will say I am definitely like I dealt
I don't need a meal right now because I
ate a lot of snacks and so yeah I think
I'm good for at least another a few
hours maybe till I get to the airport
and then I'll have to have a little
snack maybe just something that I
brought or I'll pick something up so
we'll see what I'm feeling like in that
moment all right so we're gonna have a
quick little lunch here we've got a nice
salad it's got guacamole and some corn
salsa and mango salsa and edamame and
chickpeas and black beans and some feta
cheese and lots of greens because after
all of those protein bars samples I'm
feeling like I need some veg so good I
enjoy that so in terms of themes and
trends I saw at the conference I think
for sure a lot of keto and low carb or
low sugar products as well as
gluten-free is still you know everywhere
and on top of that there was a lot of
like caffeine infused things which is
interesting I haven't seen a lot of that
before pre and probiotics as always are
really popular if there's always going
to be products being infused with pre
and probiotics and a lot of non-dairy
yogurt feel like the yogurt aisle just
continues to explode and and it's not
slowing down and now there's a lot of
like lactose free and dairy free yogurt
so for my vegan followers good news
there's a lot more products coming to
your stores just gonna curl my hair in
the bathroom at the airport well Philly
it was a great trip I'm sad to go home
but also really excited to see baby II I
really miss him leaving paste having
every single day multiple times a day
but I still just want to hug him and
yeah I'm looking forward to a very busy
week peace out
so that was like the worst flight I
think we've ever been on I feel I was
hungry now I feel pretty nauseous and
we're gonna super rush we gotta get home
see the kiddo get changed get back in a
cab and then we're going to the taste to
Canada cookbook Awards tonight because
my book my flow cookbook is nominated
for the health category so really
excited about that
I'm super exhausted but we're gonna
rally and it's gonna be a good thing
probably a really short night but we're
gonna make it
[Applause]
I'm feeling a lot better after my
horrible Naja flight and now I'm really
hungry so I got to get through this
award ceremony before we get to half a
little nosh and I'm going to get a
little snack
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to offer
[Music]
[Music]
I know if you caught that but my pulao
just won gold and I was definitely not
expecting that so super cold right now I
had some amazing people in my category I
totally thought Lauren Toyota was gonna
win because I loved her book but yeah
super exciting had some great eats shook
some hands kiss some babies now I'm
going to bed because I'm really really
tired and we've had like a long day this
feels like three days in one I can't
believe this is one one day so I'm tired
and full a bit of a headache but I'm
kind of riding on cloud nine so very
grateful very humbled and very excited
and if you don't have mindful blow check
out the link in the description because
yeah you can definitely get it so don't
forget if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you have any suggestions for
wedding in the day reviews subscribe to
this channel and I will see you next
time on hobbies kitchen
[Music]